en términos de que con cada distinto de
0 cuando es la intersección del eje con
la línea tangente a la curva f x igual a
1 entre x en el punto x igual acá bueno
entonces que nada vamos a hacer una
pequeña gráfica vamos a tratar de
visualizar esta función esta curva ahí
tengo mi eje y y por acá voy a tener mi
eje x más o menos algo así y la curva de
esa función la curva de fx igual 1 / x
se ve algo así como que por ahí se va a
infinito y después comienza a
a estabilizarse por acá y por acá tengo
el comportamiento reflejado digo esto es
una aproximación ustedes la podrían
hacer mucho mejor pero pero bueno más o
menos esta es la curva fx o la gráfica
de fx igual a 1 entre equis y entonces
quiero encontrar la línea tangente en un
punto acá acá tiene que ser distinto de
cero por supuesto si uno entre cero no
está bien definido aquí entonces acá
podría ser por ejemplo aquí este número
podría hacer acá y entonces este punto
en la curva tendría altura
uno entre acá sería uno entre acá bien
entonces la línea tangente en este punto
se vería algo así
se vería algo así y yo tengo que
encontrar o determinar cuánto vale este
punto de aquí la intersección con el eje
y entonces para hacer eso lo más fácil
es encontrar la pendiente de esta línea
tangente puesto que yo hace que este
punto este punto está sobre la gráfica y
es el punto que coma uno entre carr
por lo tanto con este punto y la
pendiente de esta recta puedo determinar
la intersección con el eje y bueno y
como encuentro la pendiente de la línea
tangente una curva pues ustedes ya saben
que lo más fácil es utilizar la derivada
así que sí fx es igual a 1 entre x pues
no voy a escribir como fx es igual a no
voy a escribir uno entre x sino x al
menos uno de ese modo es claro que lo
que voy a tratar de usar es la regla del
exponente para la derivada bueno y
entonces derivo esto y cuanto me da pues
y derivó esto obtengo que f prima de x
es igual a el exponente baja obtengo
menos 1 por x al a el exponente los
reduzco en uno así que menos uno menos
uno sería menos 2
de modo que esto es lo mismo que menos x
a la menos 2 que es lo mismo que
- 1 / x al cuadrado bien entonces en el
punto cada comuna entre cada cuánto vale
está esta derivada pues entonces f prima
en el punto k
el prima de k es igual a cuánto
pues va a ser igual a menos 1 entre ca
al cuadrado
- 1 / k al cuadrado simplemente estoy
sustituyendo este valor de modo que es
la pendiente regresando a nuestra línea
tangente podría escribir su ecuación en
la forma ordenada al origen como que es
igual a m x + b donde m es la pendiente
que precisamente es este valor de aquí y
b es justamente la ordenada al origen es
la altura de este punto de aquí así que
bien vamos a ver si sustituyó este valor
para la pendiente puede escribir la
ecuación de la línea tangente en la
forma que es igual a m pero m quien es m
es simplemente menos 1 / cuadrado menos
uno entre cada cuadrada por x por x más
algún número b entonces quiero encontrar
este número b y cómo le hago pues yo sé
que este punto aquí en este punto rosado
de aquí el punto
quería que se fuera rosado el punto cada
uno entre acá está sobre la línea
tangente porque es la línea tangente en
ese punto por lo tanto si yo sustituyo
estos valores x igual acá y llegó a la 1
entre campo de despejar a ver vamos a
ver yo tengo que es igual a 1 entre acá
por lo tanto uno entre acá tiene que ser
igual a la pendiente menos uno entre
cada cuadrado por el valor de x en el
punto pero el valor de x en el punto en
este caso es k
es que más el número ve ahora aquí está
acá cancela esté cuadrado y me queda
menos uno entre cada vez de modo que si
yo sumo si yo sumo uno entre acá de
ambos lados
uno entre cada de ambos lados vamos a
sumar estas dos ecuaciones que obtengo
obtengo uno entre camas uno entre acá
sería simplemente 2 entre k 2 entre k es
igual a este menos 1 entre acá se
cancela con este 1 entre acá y me queda
docente acá es igual a b de modo que ya
tengo el resultado que estaba buscando
ya sé cuánto vale b
ahora podría escribir la ecuación de la
línea tangente como ya es igual a la
pendiente que es menos uno entre cada
cuadrado por x + b pero ve es 2 entre k
de modo que este punto de aquí este
punto aquí es el punto 0,2 entre acá y
ya terminamos